نواصل وتغطياتنا لقمه مجموعه العشرين في
جزيره بالي الاندونيسيه التي تتم يومها
الاول وسط سعود لافته لملف الازمه
الاوكرانيه على طاوله النقاش ودعوات لوقف
الحرب التي قد تتحول الى حرب عالميه ثالثه
مستواداته بيان قمه العشرين اعتبرت في هذا
السياق الاستخدام الاسلحه النوويه
والتهديد بها غير مقبولين وجاء في المسود
ان معظم الاعضاء يدينون بشده الحرب في
اوكرانيا دعيتان الى ضروره التمديد صفقه
الحبوب الاوكرانيا واضافت المسودان
المجموعه تبدي انشغالها بتاثير الحرب في
اوكرانيا على الاقتصاد العالمي وخلال
افتتاح القمه ضد رئيس الاندلسي ودوده قاده
المجموعه على انهاء الحرب
وتجنب حرب الاخرى بين القوه الكبرى
في هذا الاطار اكد وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
مع او لو منعت السيسي البيان الختامي لقمه
العشرين مشددا على بلاده جاهزه للتفاوض
لكنه اوكرانيا هي التي ترفض التوسل
الاتفاق وذلك لان الدول الغربيه تامر
الرئيس
فلاديميرسيلنسكي بعدم الدخول في مفاوضات
مع موسكو لان الولايات المتحده والنيتهم
منخرطان في الحرب على اوكرانيا على احد
تعبئه وقال لابره بنتهامه روسيا بالعدوان
على اوكرانيا استفزاز مقصود لكن في ذات
الوقت اشار الى ان هناك الكثير من الدول
لم تنضم للعقوبات ضد روسيا مضيفا بان
عمليه تروسي العسكريه في اوكرانيا مشروعه
لكن الريسكي لا يريد السلام
من جانبه شدد المستشار الالماني واللافل
على ان افضل طريقه لتعافي الاقتصاد
العالمي هي انهاء الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا واشاره شورت خلال جلسه لقمه
العشرين بشان امن الغذاء والطاقه بان
الحرب في اوكرانيا لها تداعيات وخيمه ويجب
وقفها فورا
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
الذي يشاركه في قمه العشرين بدا لقاءاته
مع قاده العالم حيث استقبله اولا الرئيس
الاندلس ودودو الامير محمد بن سلمان التقى
ايضا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على
هامشي قمه العشرين المنعقده حاليا في بالي
كمل تقى ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان على هامش القمه برئيس وزراء
بريطانيا ريتشي سوناك وعبر سوناك عن امله
بمواصله بلاده العمل مع السعوديه من اجل
استقرار اسواق الطاقه سوناك وولي العهد
السعودي اعرب عن قلقهما تجاه التهديدات في
المنطقه بما فيها سلك ايران
كمستعرض ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان العلاقات الثنائيه وعددا من
الموضوعات ذات الاهتمام المشترك مع رئيس
دوله الامارات الشيخ محمد بن زايد
من بقالي هي انضم الينا موفد العربيه محمد
الطميحي برفقه ايضا موفده العربيه فاطمه
الضاوي مرحبا بكما فاطمه ومحمد اهلا بكم
ما في نشره الرابعه دعوني فقط ان اضع
العناوين العريضه ربما لهذه المداخله لكم
في بالي هذه القمه تعقد وسط مهددات متعدده
للاقتصاد العالمي بدء بارتفاع التضخم ازمه
الطاقه نعدم الامن الغذائي الركود العالم
المحتمل الحرب التجاريه الامريكيه همم
الصينيه ولا اضطرابات الجيوس السياسيه
الشديده التي خلفتها الحرب الروسيه
الاخرانيه هل يمكن لقمه بالي استعاده
الزخم الاقتصاد العالمي ام انها ستكون
يعني مجرد قمه اخرى لا اكثر من ذلك تفضل
خالد اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدي الرابعه
السؤال جيد ااا
كان مجموعه السبع اللي بتمثل الدول الاكبر
اقتصادا في العالم كان دائما يكون عليها
تعويم انه يصدر منها مخرجات ولكن الصوره
تغيرت خلال ثمان سنوات الماضيه بالارقام
اذا ما تحدثنا فقط عن مساهمه الناتج
المحلي للصين في الاقتصاد العالمي فهو
مرتفع او بشكل تقريبا بحسب الارقام
الرسميه حوالي
38.6 بينما امريكا والولايات المتحده
بتساهم في مجموعه اقتصادات مجموعه السبعه
فقط بحدود 18.6% فنعم الصوره تغيرت ثقل
اقتصادات مجموعه العشرين اكبر بكثير مما
هو ممثل في جي 7 وبالتالي هناك هناك
الكثير من الامال المبنيه لعل على الاقل
الاتفاق انه نحن في ازمه استثنائيه استمرت
للسنوات بداناها من كورونا ودخلنا في حرب
روسيا اوكرانيا تداعيتها كانت قويه على
جميع اركان الاقتصاد العالمي بالاضافه
بطبع الى امن الطاقه وامن الغداء نعم
بشكل قوي جدا في الكلمه التي تحيه لقمه
العشرين اليوم عندما تحدث الرئيس الامريكي
عندما تحدث بانه لا يمكن القبول بان تكون
هذه القمه مجرد بشكل او باخر حبر على ورق
يريد ان تكون هذه القمه قمه بالي همم
تغيير جذري فيما يتعلق باتخان قرارات
لانقاذ العالم مما قد ينتظرهم من مشاكل
الاقتصاديه من ركود اقتصاده عالمي خاصه في
السنه المقبله اذا لم تتخذ قرارات قويه
ولافته ولكن يبقى سؤال الاهم هل بالفعل
اتخذت هذه القرارات
نحن بانتظار البيان الختامي كل التسريبات
التي تتحدث كانت تسريبات في معظمها ربما
تسريبات سياسيه تتعلق بالازمه في اوكرانيا
تتعلق بامن القدامت الطاقه ولكن على هامش
كل هذا الاجتماعات وكل هذه اللقاءات يبدو
بان الحدث الابرز واللافه الذي يؤمن عليه
العالم كثيرا هو التقارب الصيني الغربي
شاهدنا اجتماعات ليست فقط اجتماع بايدنج
ولكن هناك اجتماعات اخرى جماعته بمكرون
جماعته برئيس الوزراء همم الاسترالي اذا
هناك اكثر من حل اكثر من ازمه نتحدث عن
ازمه تايوان المحيط الهادي نتحدث عن
العلاقه مال الاتحاد الاوروبي كان ايضا
اللقاء مع
مسؤولين اوروبيين اخرين انطلاقا من اللقاء
الذي جمعهما مع الرئيس وهذه نقطه تحاورما
في قمه ال20
من جهه القوه من يملك القوه اليوم هذا
السؤال الذي يجب ان القلب جواب اللي ملك
القوه هو اللي عنده
يلعب دور رئيسي في الاقتصادات والان هي
الصين الصين اصبحت او لاعب رئيسي لا يمكن
ان نهمشه او نعطيه اوامر لكي يتحرك على
اساسها ونجحت الصين في ذلك اذا ما ياتي
بعيدا بعد سنوات ان الحكومه الامريكيه
كانت تهاجم الصين وتهددها سواء على موضوع
الرقائق او السمكه او تايوان او ساوثريه
وتقول نحن الان مستعدون لايجاد حلول ونبني
منصه لبناء علاقه ثنائيه صحيه ايضا الصين
لربما الان تمشي نحو تحقيق اهدافها
الاستراتيجيه وايضا السياديه والاقتصاديه
ان تبقى لاعب رئيسي في الاقتصاد العالمي
النقطه اللي مهمه ايضا انه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه زارت انه دور اسيا اصبح
مهم جدا وهذا يؤكد الجوله الاسيويه التي
يقوم بها
ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان بدءا من
همم من هنا من همم من بالي انت مسافر بكره
ولا اليوم غدا ربما حتى الان لترقيه زياره
اخرى زميره ميسون وهو من العربيه ايضا في
تغطيه في كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان وهذا
يقودني ايضا الى الاجتماعات الثنائيه التي
عقدها الامير محمد بن سلمان اليوم هنا في
بالي بدا من استقبال الرئيس ودودو له في
قاعه مجموعه 23 او القاعه التي عقدت فيها
اجتماعات مجموعه العشرين كان هناك لقاء
لافت له ايضا مع رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
همم ريتشري سوناك تحدث فيها عن موضوع
الاتفاق على الا تكون ايران مهدد
للاستقرار الاقليم في المنطقه في النووي
واكيد ان الطاقه وهذا اول لقاء يجمع طبعا
مع ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان كان
هناك لقاء لافت ايضا مع رئيس دوله
الامارات العربيه المتحده الشيخ محمد زايد
ولا ننسى اللقاء الذي جماعه ايضا الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان ولكن ايضا اللقاءات
الجانبيه التي عقدت سواء في قاعه الاجتماع
او في حفل الغداء او في حفل العشاء الذي
شاهدناه قبل قليل نلاحظ ايضا اجتماعات
ثنائيه وحديث جانبي اكثر من مره تكرر
الحديث لم يا محمد بن سلمان مع الرئيس
الفرنسي ماكرون مع
المستشار الالماني شغل ايضا مع عدد من
المسؤولين كما تابعنا في اللقطات بمن فيهم
الرئيس الصيني همم
بنك بالمناسبه كيف تابعت يا فاطمه العرض
الختامي لليوم الاول من همم القمه خاصه
فيما يتعلق باحتفال رئيس ودوده
بالمشاركين في قمه العشرين
مثل اللي لابسين الرؤساء خالد دخلوا همم
قادت دول مجموعه ال 20 وكل واحد لابس قميص
من الطراز الاندونيسي بدون مختلف وهما
بيحبوا الالوان
تكون فاقعه يا اما اصفر يا اما فوشيا يا
اما بينك احنا حاولنا انه ههه
[موسيقى]
طيب انا خلوني فقط
عن هذه القمه وما يمكن ان تتمخض عنه يعني
يمكن في 2015 بعد
الحرب وانا هنا اتحدث على الجوانب
السياسيه اللي كان لا تاثير على الجوانب
الاقتصاديه بشكل كبير على على كل الجوانب
الاقتصاديه النمو غيرها من الامور وعان
العالم وما زال وعاد اليوم في حال لم
تكن هناك حلول ربما للحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
واذا كانت هناك مشكله اخرى
قد تكون اكثر واصعب اللي هي حرب صينيه او
حرب الصين
م- من خلال هذه القمه مع هكذا احتمالات
خطيره همم محمد وفاطمه
خلينا نبدا بالصين ذكرت همم مخاطر الحرب
الصينيه مع تايوان همم هذا اتى على لسان
تشيكن انه فعلا الان سوف يراجع هذه
العلاقه وانه بدا يسمع الى الجهات الغربيه
او الولايات المتحده بايجاد علاقه او
خلينا نقول معادله لاعاقه جديده اللي
هيرسمها مع تايوان وبالتالي هذا السوق
وشوفنا الاسواق الاسيويه مرتفعه صباحا
اليوم كان في تفاعل قبل المستثمرين اللي
راقبوا هذا الاجتماع لاول منه
ايضا رئاسه الولايات المتحده همم اشاره
ايجابيه انه فعلا الصين انه العلاقه بدات
تتغير الافضل هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى همم
على حسب التسريبات في مسوده
البيان الختام المفروض يصدر غدا انه
اول مره بنشوف لربما التحذير او اجماع من
معظم اعضاء مجموعه 20 بدينه الحرب الروسيه
في اوكرانيا
تدان الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا معظم
القاده وبالتالي خرج وزير الخارجيه الروسي
وتحدث عن ان هناك محاولات
لادانه روسيا بشكل مباشر وبالتالي لن يصدر
بيان من هذا النوع الكل يتحدث عن الحل
السلم كيف هذا هو الحل هذا هو الاختلاف
وبالتالي انهاء الحرف اوكرانيا الجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات ولكن ليس كما يريد
الاتحاد الاوروبي ليس كما تريد الولايات
المتحده بادانه وواضحه لموسكو فيما يتعلق
بهذا الحرب ولكن هناك ملفات نختم بهذه
الملفات بارزه فيما يتعلق بالاتفاقيات
الثنائيه الجانبيه التي تساهم بشكل كبير
في تراجع التضخم في مساعده الدول اكثر
فقره فيما يتعلق بالدور الذي تقوم به
مجموعه العشرين وليس فقط الازمه في
اوكرانيا والعلاقات مع الصيد
ايضا تكررت كثيرا وبالتالي نتامل انه هذا
الاجتماع في بالي جزيره الالهه كما يصفها
السياح الاندونيسيين يطلع منها نتيجه
ايجابيه هذه
ونعود بشكل اقوى كما تقول قمه العشرين في
ذلك شكرا جزيلا لكم بالتاكيد همم تتابع
معكم الزملاء فينا شرات لاحقا كل تطورات
هذه القمه من بالي محمد طويحي وفاطمه
الضاوي
مع قمه العشرين اكد السفير الاندونيسيه
لدى السعوديه الدكتور عبد العزيز احمد في
مقابله مع العربيه ان العلاقات مع
السعوديه شهدت تطورا كبيرا في الاوله
الاخيره
مين قدوه النجاره
[موسيقى]